first peppers cut around the flat edges
to minimize waste then chop the nice
thing about making a Smasher there's no
set recipe because you can pull it
together purely all Tomatoes half
peppers half Tomatoes I like the flavor
of the cucumber in there as well that
gives it that freshness the secret of a
great dispatcher is the longer you leave
it marinating the better the flavor so
you can get this done the night before
and left in the fridge the results are
stunning the green and red peppers have
subtly complementary flavors and go well
with ripe tomatoes start off by removing
the bitter core a little knife and just
put it in where the core is and twist it
round and you get this little core out I
remember my first experience eating a
gazpacho in Spain mind blowing I've
never forgotten that quarter your
tomatoes keeping the juicy seeds that
add so much depth of taste nice then
from there cucumber just peel that seeds
and I leave in that gives it the flavor
and the texture cucumber a dispatcher
does exactly what it does in a Pimm's it
sort of freshens it up makes it
mouth-watering slice that in half again
into quarters and chopped
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup bread and the
crispy the crust the better then garlic
thinly sliced next spring onions nice
and roughly chopped and basil stalks and
all we can use stalks and Buzzle stalks
parsley stalks tarragon stores they have
the most amazing flavor basil in and now
we will start marinating salt black
pepper and a good coating of olive oil
this gives it a glossy creamy flavor
i'ma show you vinegar that's the perfect
vinegar for the gazpacho it's a strong
acidic complement to the flavors then
just mix it up your smell already is
incredible it doesn't look like a
gazpacho but by Chinese marinades and
all those flavors start getting to know
one another all of a sudden you've got
this huge explosion of contrast now push
that down in the restaurants we press
the marinade down overnight a couple of
big pans on top and we crush all the
ingredients and then blitz it the next
day flavor is extraordinary leave all
those fresh ingredients packed with
goodness to marinade from half an hour
to even overnight and then when you
blend it it just comes together like
this sumptuous rich delicious and
chilled soup to go with my super tasty
soup I've got an ultra healthy and
exciting dessert carpaccio of pineapple
which is a Chevy way of saying super
thinly sliced it's done with a twist
we're gonna have a delicious flavored
salt has we flavored with vanilla simply
scrape out the vanilla seeds and add to
sea salt along with the pod to store
now that basically keeps River there's
no sell-by date because it's salt and
vanilla so so fragrant so delicious you
don't need much of this fragrant salt to
intensify the sweetness of the pineapple
pineapple slice peel pineapple into
weight for thin pieces so a nice look
this slightly transparent once you've
sliced the pineapple take the flavour to
another level a light sprinkle of
vanilla salt and arrange the pineapple
in a flower shape
[Music]
it's a beautiful way of finishing a male
the fragrance other than the crunch with
the salt on the vanilla salt just
marinades the pineapple beautifully then
scatter nutrient-rich pomegranate seeds
over the top to finish finely shredded
fresh mint just slice them really thin
and then I'll give that nice cool minty
flavor pineapple my carpaccio is ready
and my gazpacho has been marinating in
the fridge I blend the soup uncha
blender and start off nice and slowly
blend until super fine and glossy silky
and serve refreshingly cold
get the ball and play
now to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight and shred it and
then drop it into your bowl fresh
chopped basil and then finally just a
touch of extra virgin olive oil just to
give that really nice additional
freshness and look at that healthy and
delicious
[Music]
gazpacho soup to me is a taste of
Mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the wafer-thin carpaccio or
pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
practically all of your five a day in
one incredible healthy lunch